um yeah no yes
my favorite laser is kangaroo what is
yours alright what is this a slim ask my
limb commit yourself or check in are
there uh well what the [ __ ] that was
creepier than I thought
happiness
I can't believe there's so many people
live it's crazy all right it's going
here
whoa turn your lights off and put on
headphones you'll need all home alone
oh god it's so loud
so
is this all I could do it's pretty much
fullscreen annually oh my hello the
graphics are amazing
what is this
at 23
one is not like the others alright whoa
whoa
Oh what the [ __ ]
nope
got that now
did I die I see yes all right let's try
again she lives in darkness
what
oh I don't settings me show me your
fight oh my god are you serious no way I
don't want to play this it's just Oh
though go back upstairs though though
look go back upstairs
turn around I can't come ah
oh my god
oh did I die again why do I keep dying
I'll try again
whew stairs
yeah it's going here
nope alright stairs is so much fun yeah
who
yeah yeah hello
creepy station I got a [ __ ] AMA creep
earth god damn it's so freaking loud my
neighbors must be [ __ ] what I mean
what nope hey babies nope nope
nope don't you dare this
hahaha okay okay
she likes he's calm I get it I get it I
get no bra just spend the thing spin
around no problem
yeah yeah yeah
how long do I have to spin this
did I make it yeah no creepy lady I mean
baby here
I got toes no
how do I walk quietly
don't wait
oh I get it I get it oh my toes are so
hot it's ridiculous no don't go there
nope nope Oh mother of penis everywhere
though what the [ __ ] are you serious I
don't wanna know this anymore
what fun ah [ __ ] babies man [ __ ]
babies alright let's do this again let's
sneak your little [ __ ]
oh no ha ha no brah ha ha blam I can
know this just keep the balance with the
my house
yeah no problem no creepy babies keep
the battles keep the bowels keep the bag
laughs get the bags
nope nope nope yeah nope ball up no no
yes no late go States they say success
is assisi oh [ __ ]
ah
helpless [ __ ] you I'm not helpless I can
do this
what
I'll play Oh what the [ __ ]
I'll play this for another 50 minutes
and I really got to go guys
I haven't even played today's penumbra
I love you guys but I have school
tomorrow
what the [ __ ] is that anyway
sup dog
let's make out your hop
all right if it only 15 minutes and I'll
finish it it looks like we're almost
halfway
am I missing something here I didn't
look
guess I'll tell me what I'm supposed to
do
goodnight rig 10
six it better not be [ __ ] wrong I
swear God
No
no no nope
alright let's take a look again spider
okay six six five four five
what the [ __ ]
what why Oh nope
he really wants to make out who was
setting the mood I like it had no oh
dude that was just disgusting forget
that skip Taiwan